My name is Maria Angela Villalba from the
Philippines.
I run the political enterprise for Unlad Kabayan,
it's a very lofty one.
Now, the question of, "Will geopolitical conflicts
outweigh the economic prices in East Asia"
is a difficult question.
And it really depends, one, on how long this
economic crisis will last. If it deepens,
it can be an area that people will concentrate
on.
However, if there is a recovery and the geopolitical
conflicts intensify, as it is, for instance
in Pakistan, North Korea, in Japan, and here
we have a brewing thing in Iran.
Now if these develop any faster, and the recovery
in the economy, the recovery in the developing
resources, for global areas, those areas of
conflict, we can gather those, for cooperation.
Involve the players in the global economy
who care, like Britain, and that is for the
players, to really win a new war.